hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're
looking at game 12 the final game in the
2018 World Chess Championship between
Magnus Carlsen The Champion and Fabiano
Caruana
they had a day off yesterday to prepare
for this one they've had 11 straight
draws for those not keeping up with the
tournament's scheduled for 12 games and
the first 11 have all been drawls
Fabiano does get the white pieces today
Magnus Carlsen will be defending with
the black pieces just kind of cool to
think about that one of these players
can win this game the final game and
then walk off as the world champion will
go ahead and get into it with Fabiano
starting as he has the past two times
his white pawn to e4 this is silly
defense Knight f3 knight c6 and then
pawn to d4 nice he's chosen this one the
past couple times at the beginning of
the tournament
it was the same Sicilian defense but
instead we saw Bishop coming here to b5
has opted for the pawn to d4 in the past
couple after the knight takes the same
variations that we have seen Knight
coming up here to b5 critical move in
this opening in particular pawn to d6
and that appeared to d5 after the knight
captures pawn to d5 and then Magnus
Carlsen decides to be the first one to
deviate from the normal plan that we've
seen the past two times and each time
for those who have been following along
I said I wonder if Magnus Carlsen is
gonna play Knight to e7 I feel like
that's more in line with what he wants
to be doing and those other two games he
played Knight to b8 but in this one he
does exactly that it plays Knight to e7
so I was a little excited to see this
how Magnus Carlsen would continue pawn
to c4 so normally you're gonna if the
knight comes to b8 you're not really
threatened you know with this pawn here
on a d5 so you can just push here on a4
give this Knight and nice little outpost
but once the knight comes to e7
attacking the pawn the common move what
Fabiana decides to play is pawned
to see for protecting this palm also
does have an outpost if you won't start
pushing on the queenside he can do that
as well
Mendez Carlson continues his line of
going against the normal mozi plays
Knight to g6 much more common would be
night down here to f5 both these players
though they're going extremely fast if
you're watching it you knew that the
moves were around seven to eight seconds
each so this was definitely in his
preparation Queen to a four this is just
opening up the opportunity for a
discovered attack Knight to c7
is the threat there's only one real
option that black has here it's Bishop
to d7 you don't want to play anything
else yes you still have to worry about
the knight coming up here to c7 at some
point but this does block a lot of the
threats that you have you can see how
different it is if you try to block this
with Queen to d7 when the night comes up
here the Queen can't take where if the
bishops here that the Queen can take and
then you could say okay King to d8 one
the King can't castle anymore the Queen
can now capture after the bishop takes
then the Knights gonna take here on a
eight this is gonna be extremely bad so
definitely need to play Bishop to d7 to
attack the Queen if the knight moves as
well as keep the Queen here on D a to
defend this square here on c7 the bishop
or the excuse me the Queen comes here to
b4 does want to be prepared you know
something like Bishop to e2 is not gonna
work because pawn to a6 this is gonna
force the knight to move and then the
Queen is gonna be a sitting target for
the bishop on d7 just eyeing down that
Queen so does need to move the Queen
Fabiano and so decides to go with Queen
to b4 Bishop down here to f5 and then
pawn age four so if I'll be able to
deciding to push on the King side the
board with two active minor pieces does
not look like especially anytime soon
Fabio is gonna be castling on the King
side magnus carlsen doesn't want Fabiana
push up too much pawn to a
five already gets somewhat uncomfortable
for magnus carlsen so he responds with
his own pawn here to h5 now white plays
Queen to a4 seems like it's a filler
move
Fabiano has to know Magnus Carson only
has one move and that's Bishop back here
to d7 we've already seen this already
blacks I'm gonna try to be cute yes the
Queen here on d8 and the knight on g6
are attacking the pot but you don't want
to take the pawn on h4 because you're
not worried about Knight to c7 that's
still a real threat but the real threat
now is Knight takes on d6 this is a
double check any time two pieces are
attacking the king the king is forced to
move no other option so let's say King
to e7 one that's a very exposed King but
then pawn appear to c5 this is putting a
lot of pressure this now opens up the
door for the Queen on a4 to attack this
night here on h4 the rook is already
attacking it but this is just supporting
the night here on d6 the Queen canal
easily getting involved into the game
the bishop here on f1 can get involved a
lot of different threats that white has
here doesn't really matter how black is
going to respond it's all going to be
bad you know maybe we see Bishop to d7
attacking the Queen the Queen comes over
here to h4 maybe pawn f6 to stop that
night on b7 taking pawn attacking the
Queen right here the Queen could move
Bishop up here to a6 you just see this
is extremely bad so not something the
Magnus Carlsen is going to fall for he
just brings his bishop back to to d7 but
you can see how many pieces and pawns
are open up for both sides to attack and
one simple mistake can lead to a
downfall very very quickly so Queen to
b4 but you back here f5 this is two-fold
repetition then we see Bishop to e3 pawn
to a6 says yeah I just don't want to
worry about this anymore let's go ahead
and kick this Knight back Knight comes
back here to c3
to c7 this is another one of those
places you don't want to take with the
nights if the night takes here on h4
then pawn to c5 this opens up a lot of
threats but maybe now the knight decides
to move because we can see the Queen and
the rook are now eyeing down this knight
so then the knight could come back here
to g6 don't want to lose that one but
then the Queen to a4 is tough to do with
maybe Bishop to d7 as we've seen in the
past but that doesn't work because of
pawn to c6 yes the pawn could take pawn
recapture you can see here this is all
bad if the bishop now moves then pawn up
here to c7 this is a discovered attack
also attacking the Queen Queen could
come up here to d7
but then Bishop to b5 pinning down the
Queen yes the panca tape but the Queen
could take up here on a eight check and
you could see as the pawn pushes forward
just through so many threats on board
that dark square Bishop can get involved
things would go extremely bad if this
happened so in the game we don't see the
knight take on h4 Bobby I was just
allowing Magnus Carlsen to do that he's
not going to they plays Queen to c7
Fabiana recognizes he doesn't have any
strong attacks on the Queen side instead
decides to play pawn to g3 just
solidifying his pawn chain on the King
side doesn't want any to worry about
this that over here to h4 and also just
wants to solidify this square here on f4
the knight can easily come down here to
f4 it's a great outpost because the pawn
here on e5 so wants to support that
Bishop to e7 just wants to get it
somewhat involved into the action and
then pawn to f3 interesting move from
Fabiano he had a couple options he could
have played Bishop to e2 just to give
his LightSquared bishop involved into
the game he could have gone full Yolo
and castle on the Queen side and said
yeah let's just have a strong attack
here chose not to do that instead play
pawn to f3 does signal that probably not
gonna be castling on the King side of
the board but a curious move all
together in my mind Knight to f8 from
Magnus Carlsen he's not gonna bring it
to e6 the only reason you're gonna bring
this back is to come over here to d7 and
then centralize with c5 this is
outpost that's what we're gonna be
seeing from Magnus Carlsen we assume
Knight to e4 centralizing that knight
Knight to d7 Bishop up here to d3 just
adding another defender on the knight
here castle on the King side and then
rook to h2 preparing to swing over to
the C file and then rook to c8 I always
want to get your books on semi open
files they just control more of the
board and starts to attack your
opponent's here castle on the Queen side
so if you look at this this is a pretty
exciting board state I don't feel like
we've had one this exciting in some time
in the World Championship we're 22 moves
in we only have one piece in one pawn
off the board all the major pieces are
there each side is castle on the
opponent's or the opposite side so
there's just everything there to throw
everything you have at your opponent so
many different lines that each side can
go into that would be disastrous and the
time starting to tick down they don't
have as much time as they've had in the
past and they're in uncharted territory
they've never seen this particular line
as they went through even after you know
move 13 so they've they've been trying
to figure out how to navigate this but
definitely looks like there's going to
be fireworks in this position bicha
comes back here to g6 in this position
black seems to have a cramped position I
would probably choose Fabiano setup
right now he plays rook to c2 and then
f5 so Magnus Carlsen gets pretty
aggressive and says yeah mats who
worried about my King safety I already
have pawn here to h5 I'm gonna just push
over here I want to get that Knights
back Knight comes back here to f2 and
then Knight down to c5 so and just a
couple of moves you can see how magnus
carlsen he's going for it he's being
extremely aggressive and in this
position I think Fabiano has to
recognize that
Magnus Carlsen has the upper hand here
and I think he needs to start to
exchange material Bishop takes on c5 the
Knights already attacking the bishop you
don't want to swing it back and be you
know in a
less aggressive position so you're
probably gonna lose a bishop if that's
the case I would rather just go ahead
and take right away pawn or the Queen
could take or the pawn could take Queen
takes here rook takes pawn up here to b4
rook comes back I think this is fun you
start to trade down a little bit you're
not in as much trouble I think that's
the plant Fabiana should have gone with
instead he decides not much is going on
the Queen side I'm gonna push up here to
F 4 and then pawn a5 so Magnus Carlsen
continues his push Queen comes back here
to D - it's really defense mode for
Fabiano pawn to e4 forcing the bishop
back things do not look good it's a
cramped position from Fabiano where does
he really go from here
Bishop comes back here to e8 so that it
can get more involved easily come here
to a4 start an attack can push down here
to b5 it protects that as well so a lot
of different options from Magnus Carlsen
plays King over here to be one could at
some point play pawn to b3 but that's
just extending pawns in front of his
King not something I think he wants to
be doing here Bishop to f6 eyeing down
the Queen side of the board where the
king is at rook to e1 sure not doing too
much but there's not many places to go
here pawn to a4 Queen up here to be 4
and then pawn g6 rook to d1 just going
back and forth you can see Fabiana is at
a loss of what he wants to do and then
Madison plays rook to a 8th and in this
position we're 31 moves in they have 9
moves before they get to the next time
Bank and Fabiano only has 9 minutes left
things are not looking good for Fabiano
so many possibilities for Magnus Carlsen
if anyone is gonna win it clearly looks
like Magnus Carlsen is going to be that
person in the 12th game I feel like this
is exactly what Magnus Carlsen is
looking for this is the first game where
it felt like Magnus Carlsen had the
upper hand as far as preparation in the
opening it was something that Fabiana
has been playing the entire tournament
Magnus Carlsen came
out of the middlegame with a better
position you can see right here
definitely is the aggressor and as
Fabiana was thinking in his thirty
second move magnus carlsen reaches his
hand out and offers a drawl the most
shocking draw I have seen in a very long
time for a second I thought he was just
taunting him basically say I know I'm
gonna win I'm gonna shake your hand I
know he wouldn't actually do that I just
when I saw it was just caught me by
surprise recognising that he was in fact
offering a drawl just makes no sense at
all to me there's no way magnus carlsen
is gonna lose this game there's a fire
that seems to have left Magnus cross in
it this was the first championship when
he was playing vision on back in the day
he would have played this to a hundred
and sixty moves if he thought he just
had the slightest edge he would try to
win but he decided after 31 moves keep
mine they have to play to 30 move so he
may have even tried to draw on earlier
but he decided to go for the draw they
asked him afterwards he said I just
didn't just didn't feel him II didn't
want to go for for the wind today even
in the position that he felt like he was
a little bit better
Fabiano on the other hand he felt like
he got off easy here he did not like his
position he felt if anything black was
definitely better he was gonna try for a
draw he was very surprised that Magnus
Carlsen extended his hand for the draw
so after 12 games we have 12 draws in a
row so what does that mean that means we
get some bonus chests in two days
tomorrow we will have the day off rest
day on Tuesday and then we come back on
Wednesday for the tiebreaker and there
will be a champion so if you're not
familiar with how the tiebreaker is
gonna be set up they first start off
with rapid chess and what that means is
they will play four games we at least
get four games on Wednesday no matter
what it's 25 minutes on your clock and
you get 10 seconds added each time you
move they will go back and forth Magnus
Carlsen will start off with the white
pieces and they will each have white
twice and they'll each have the black
twice so after that
for you get one points for winning half
a point for drawing if there is someone
who has more points at the end of those
four games they will be the champion if
it's still tied which who even knows if
someone can possibly win and one of
these games then they will go to blitz
blitz is gonna be a series of mini
one-on-ones and what that means is that
the time controls they have five minutes
and then for each move they'll get three
seconds added on but they'll play is
white and then they'll play is back
that's a miniseries if you know if
there's a win in a draw whoever got the
win they will be victorious
they'll play five of those so a lot of
opportunity for someone to win that at
least one of those miniseries if any of
those many series are won by one person
it's over they're not gonna play all
five of those if by chance there's a
draw laughter all of those then we play
armed again I don't think we'll get
there but for those who are not familiar
with armed again it works like this one
player playing the white pieces has five
minutes person with the black pieces has
four minutes you get no time after each
move after 61 moves you do start getting
three seconds every move but if it's a
drawl Black is victorious so there will
be a winner there will be a loser so
that is how Armageddon will work again I
don't think we will get there but that's
the tiebreakers on Wednesday pretty
bummed that magnus carlsen did not want
to play this one out but we do have a
drawl in game 12 thank you guys so much
for watching all the videos excited to
see who comes out victorious on
Wednesday but I will see you guys then
thanks again for watching